a big concern for millions of american
families the skyrocketing cost of
everyday items in stores average
consumer prices are up seven and a half
percent over the past 12 months that is
a fresh 40-year high putting it into
dollars moody analytics estimates that
the it's costing the average american
family an extra
276 dollars per month president biden
was asked yesterday when we should
expect some relief he said quote it
ought to be able to start to taper off
as we go through this year
ed o'keefe is at the white house for us
ed good morning to you the president has
a lot to point to showing the economy is
strong but these inflation figures are a
real problem they sure are tony good
morning and the president essentially
asking for patience as polls show that
is that he's taking a hit as americans
are now shelling out even more money
consider some of these numbers the cost
of a new vehicle more than 12 percent
the cost of furniture up more than 9
and the amount you're paying at the
grocery store up 7.4 percent compared to
this time a year ago
inflation is up
it's up
but americans don't need the reminder
delivery
costs like product costs everything
seems like it's going up
prices are skyrocketing with no signs
they're coming down soon gas prices up a
whopping 40 percent furniture used cars
and electricity also seeing a surge
at the grocery store staples like eggs
and pork are more expensive with the
cost of food you just have to bite the
bullet and
you know some things
you just have to sacrifice the white
house says it supports whatever steps
the federal reserve might take to ease
the crunch but there's little more the
biden administration can do to drive
down prices republicans blame the
democratic party's spending plans passed
in the last year this is a direct result
of liberal
policy choices
during a visit to virginia mr biden said
proposals like his buildback better plan
which is dead as written up on capitol
hill could help bring down costs but the
fact is that
if we're able to do the things i'm
talking about here
it'll bring down the cost for average
families it will not increase the debt
but senator joe manchin that moderate
democrat who helped kill the president's
spending plan amid his concerns it would
accelerate inflation
is once again sounding the alarm this
inflation is real it's harming people
you don't throw more fuel on the fire
that's already on fire causing the
problems that we have
a recent cbs news poll found that about
two-thirds of americans feel the
administration hasn't done enough to
tackle inflation in the president's
first year in office making this issue
one of his and the democratic party's
biggest political hurdles to clear with
the midterm elections fast approaching
vlad
yeah ed and if the fed chooses to raise
rates that could slow growth another
problem for the president thank you very
much ed